As a child, did you ever skin your knee and
fear telling your parents, afraid of your
mom breaking out the brown bottle of pain
containing hydrogen peroxide to “help heal”
your wound?
Given the agony it caused, you might have
wondered whether the fizzing liquid was actually
helping, and why hydrogen peroxide bubbles
when it comes in contact with your skin.
If you’re still wondering today, well, wonder
no more.
To begin with, hydrogen peroxide does indeed
kill bacteria, viruses, fungi and a whole
host of pathogens thanks to the fact that
it is a powerful oxidizing agent.
So in theory it seems like a great idea to
pour it on a fresh cut to help prevent infection.
It turns out, however, that while this has
been a staple home treatment for cleaning
various cuts and abrasions for nearly a century,
you probably shouldn’t use hydrogen peroxide
to disinfect your wounds.
To better understand why not, we’ll need
to look at what hydrogen peroxide is and how
it manages to kill microorganisms.
hydrogen-peroxideChemically speaking, hydrogen
peroxide, which is a naturally occurring molecule
within the human body, is two parts hydrogen
and two parts oxygen (H2O2), with the molecule
held together by the two oxygen atoms.
As a result of these oxygen atoms having a
very weak bond, the molecule breaks down rather
easily, potentially introducing free radicals
into your system.
Left unchecked, this would all result in a
host of problems within the human body.
In fact, because hydrogen peroxide’s claim
to fame is primarily its great oxidizing effect,
up until relatively recently it was thought
that its presence in the body had only damaging
effects.
However, recent research, such as that performed
by the German Cancer Research Center (Deutsches
Krebsforschungszentrum) in 2014 was able to
show that hydrogen peroxide is an essential
chemical messenger helping the body’s cells
respond to outside hormones and growth factors.
As Dr. Tobias Dick sums up, “We know today
that the body’s own H2O2 is vital for signal
processing in a healthy organism.”
That said, the level of H2O2 must be maintained
in a specific range (between 0.05 micromol/l
and 117 micromol/l in exhaled breath, and
in human fluid).
Too much and the damaging effects of oxidation
will cause countless problems that can result
in cell death, among other issues.
Enter the enzyme catalase, which is found
in almost all living things.
Catalase circulates throughout the cell, waiting
to come into contact with the H2O2 being produced
by cellular respiration.
Once in contact, it rapidly converts it into
water and oxygen (via two H2O2 molecules becoming
two H2O (water) molecules and one O2 (dioxygen)
molecule).
In fact, the catalase is so good at its job,
that it has one of the highest chemical conversion
rates of any enzyme.
A single catalase molecule can convert millions
of hydrogen peroxide molecules every second.
(It is this water and oxygen being rapidly
produced that results in the fizzing/bubbling
effect you see when the hydrogen peroxide
comes in contact with the catalase.)
However, even with this efficiency, residual
hydrogen peroxide will remain, allowing your
body to maintain the low concentration of
hydrogen peroxide required for normal protein
signaling, while keeping it from reaching
toxic levels that can destroy a cell.
Like all living things, bacteria, viruses,
and many other pathogens have a myriad of
chemical reactions taking place within their
cells.
Just as the oxidizing effects of hydrogen
peroxide can ultimately potentially interrupt
these processes, it can also do the same to
bacterial cells.
Thus, if this oxidizing agent is in high enough
concentration, the result is a halt to normal
cellular processes resulting in the death
of the pathogen.
So why the controversy today on whether you
should use hydrogen peroxide on wounds?
As just mentioned, this oxidizing agent will
also kill healthy human cells in sufficient
concentration.
Beyond this, it’s also thought that it may
slow down the mechanisms of healing because
it interferes with the normal scaffolding
processes involved with repairing skin damage.
(This interruption can also potentially lead
to increased scarring, see: How Scars Form.)
This is all not to mention that if the oxygen
gas produced by the large amount of hydrogen
peroxide coming in contact with the catalase
enters your blood stream, it can circulate
throughout your body leading to countless
medical problems like heart attack, stroke,
or pulmonary embolus.
While you might think this couldn’t possibly
happen, hydrogen peroxide used as a topical
disinfectant has been implicated in several
fatal and near fatal incidents due to this
oxygen gas being introduced into the bloodstream.
However, as yet it’s not entirely clear
how the oxygen is getting there.
It may be that excess oxygen enters the capillary
beds themselves, or that H2O2 (hydrogen peroxide)
molecules get absorbed into the bloodstream
and then, in such relatively high concentration,
create the oxygen embolus.
Whatever the mechanism, the potentially life
threatening complication remains.
So in the end, thanks to the propensity of
hydrogen peroxide to cause damage to healthy
tissue, combined with the very slight risk
of oxygen emboli after pouring it on a cut,
the use of hydrogen peroxide to clean wounds
is usually not recommended anymore, presumably
much to the relief of six year olds the world
over.
As for what you should do when cleaning wounds,
most doctors will point out simply using normal
saline, a little elbow grease, and some over
the counter topical antibacterial products
will have a much greater chance of preventing
infection then the hydrogen peroxide would
anyway.